le 22 septembre,
pour la musique, nous vous avons entendu, ça
va être amusant,
rond
et clair, s'il vous plaît,
faites Expendables pour une note R,
il vaut mieux qu'il y ait de la violence et beaucoup de violence,
je veux tout le sang et les tripes, merde
[Musique]
tout d'abord, [ __ ] de merde dans
mon esprit  est plein de ces beaux fantasmes fantasmes
[Musique]
qui vont maintenant devenir une réalité sans tête
c'est une excellente idée
et bien je ne joue plus,
attends,
tu es mon [ __ ], tue-moi, tu es le bienvenu
maintenant c'est de cela que je parle
Je suis content d'être de retour
[Musique]
profitez du spectacle
Expendables définitivement
classé R dans
les cinémas le 22 septembre